getting into law school is hard enough
but doing well once you get in that is a
whole nother ballgame so how did I learn
to do well in law school including
straight A's my first semester wouldn't
you like to know
[Music]
hey legal eagles D James Stone here
teaching you how to think like a lawyer
so you can crush law school I've been a
big firm lawyer for over ten years but
before that I went to law school just
like every other attorney the thing is
when I got to law school I completely
freaked out I wanted to be a lawyer for
as long as I could remember and I knew
that that meant going to law school but
nothing could prepare me for what law
school was actually like a lot of kids
come into law school and they're worried
because they don't know anything about
the law I didn't exactly have that
problems because number one I had tons
of confidence maybe way too much
confidence but I'd also had you know
experience with mock trial and I'd
watched hours and hours of Law & Order
so I felt like I had sort of a handle on
the law itself but then I got to class
and then I realized that I knew
absolutely nothing about the law and not
only that but the quality of the student
in law school is unlike anything I'd
experienced in college the kids that
come from Yale and Harvard they just
have this swagger and I have never been
in a room with such a high concentration
of just a type personalities and people
that were just intellectually stunning
just so many smart people all in one
place and then of course there are the
Gunners and a gunner is someone who
always raises their hand they're always
trying to answer the questions they
think they know more than they do and
and they think it's their duty to
explain to the professor all of the
things that they know they're really
obnoxious and they're really hard to
avoid but the problem is when you're a
first-year law student you can't tell
the Gunners from the genuine geniuses
either they just seem like they have all
the answers and
seem like they have the right answers to
you get to law school and you're
surrounded by these unbelievably
brilliant people and you're also trying
to learn essentially a new vocabulary
you're learning new substantive law that
you've never seen in your entire life
and every class basically has its own
vocabulary such that it's like learning
a different language but and it's like
learning French German and Spanish all
at the same time in in different classes
so it's just completely overwhelming
when you get to law school so my vision
for what law school was going to be like
did not match up with a reality and you
know I tried to do my best I tried to do
the readings I tried to engage with the
professor's but there's just so much out
there and I remember one time in
criminal law where we were discussing
the different forms of criminal homicide
and I thought I spotted a flaw in the
professor's argument so I raised my hand
and I explained my argument and I said
you know professor isn't that just a
semantic difference thinking I was going
to win this argument and the professor
retorted back well is it everything a
semantic difference aren't we always
talking about the differences between
the definitions of words and it got a
huge laughs in front of the class and
and I felt humiliated and I didn't
realize I was going to have to be
debating with essentially a postmodern
professor and who was a total relativist
but you know he made a good point and
I'll never forget you know what it felt
like to be skewered at the end of a
logical knife of this this professor but
that was not a situation that I was used
to being in and yet every single day in
class I would find myself on the horns
of a dilemma or you know I wouldn't
understand the arguments that were being
made or I felt like I just couldn't keep
up with the readings and the arguments
that were going on in class now in the
past it was rare that I didn't think
that I was one of the smartest people in
the room but in law school I definitely
was not the smartest person in the room
and I probably wasn't even in the top
half I mean I really felt like I was
surrounded by intellectual geniuses and
after class it seemed like everyone was
actually studying harder than I was I
don't know how it was possible but they
seemed to find more time in the day to
study to read their cases to read
supplements everyone was not only really
smart but no one was slacking off and
everyone was incredibly hard worker so I
knew that I had to figure something out
because I couldn't just skate by with
the the habits that I had in undergrad
and procrastinating like I used to I
knew that I was gonna have to have some
different tactic in law school because
otherwise I was just gonna get left
behind by my classmates and I knew that
I just couldn't rely on innate talent
because everyone seemed to be incredibly
talented but worse than that everyone
seemed to be working at least as hard if
not harder so I knew that I couldn't
rely on innate talent and I also
couldn't outwork my cohort either I
realized I had to come up with with a
system I had to try something different
so I in addition to studying the law for
my classes I also decided to study law
school itself I figured there there must
be a way to go about it better and
smarter so I read everything I possibly
could about the tactics of law school
itself and I got tips from upperclassmen
I talked to them about what worked in
their first year and what didn't work I
talked to practicing attorneys I really
tried to reach out to get as much
on-the-ground experience as I could
because I figured that experience is the
best teacher and you know you only get
one shot at your first year in law
school so I really had to make the most
of it and it really seemed like after
you go through your first year all the
upperclassmen were completely changed
and so I had to figure out how they made
that transition and how they learned to
do
what worked in and discarded what what
didn't work so in addition to reading
about law school itself I started
reading about practice exams and I not
only that but I tried to do as many
practice exams as possible in those days
there used to be more public databases
where you could go to different law
schools web sites and you could download
more past exams and I figured that there
might be some commonalities between
different exams and lo and behold I
found that almost everyone used this
weird sort of law school exam called an
issue spotting exam where you're given a
fact pattern and what I found is that
issue spotting exams were really unlike
any of the stuff that you do in class in
law school when you're in class you're
basically doing appellate opinion
autopsies so you get an opinion from an
appellate court that lays out the facts
and the legal reasoning and comes out
with a particular holding and you're
basically doing a dissection or an
autopsy of that opinion but the thing is
you're not tested on almost any of that
information the amount of information
that you glean from a particular case is
so small compared to what you actually
do on a final exam and because there are
so many commonalities between the final
exams I figured out what works for those
finals
and I learned that the kind of in-class
dissection that you do on a pellet
opinions well that's important and you
use that in practice you don't really
use it on the final exam so I really
emphasized my practice exams I really
emphasized learning the strategies of
how to write a really good issue
spotting exam answer because all the
finals are basically the same format and
in the end of the day all the strategies
that I come up with all the experience
that I got from the upperclassmen and
all the experience that I had doing my
practice
exams ended up having a good result I
remember my first semester when I got
the report card and it's given to you in
an envelope and so much relies on those
grades I mean you use your first
semester grades to get your your 1l
summer job when you come back for your
second year to do interviews with law
firms like all they look at basically
are your first year grades and when I
got that first report card I had in my
hand and my hands were shaking and I I
just couldn't open it up in the the
classroom that we were giving it to so I
walked outside UCLA law has this really
beautiful courtyard that's surrounded on
three sides by buildings it's got huge
trees and I sat down on a bench I opened
up and I saw the picket fence
ay-ay-ay and we only had three classes
that semester and I got I got straight
A's and to this day I don't think I've
ever had a single better feeling moment
than when I picked up the phone and I
called my parents and I said hey mom and
dad I just got my first semester grades
I want you to know I got straight A's
everything is gonna be okay and my
parents were yelling and crying and it
was it was just one of the best moments
I've ever had in my entire life and it
as I predicted it would it sent me up
for a really good first year job it set
me up for getting the big firm job that
I wanted in Los Angeles and nothing has
really ever compared to that and and
frankly you know your first semester is
is so important it's by far the most
important part of Law School
and I was able to keep up the momentum I
graduated with a whole lot more A's and
the next two and a half years of law
school were intense but they were they
were nothing like that first semester I
used a lot of those skills in mock trial
and moot court where I went on to when
couple of national tournaments and
between my grades and my
extracurriculars I was able to get set
up to work for a big firm an AM la 100
firm in Los Angeles and I was able to
get my dream job as a civil litigator
and I've been the litigator ever since
now the the story of how I became a big
firm lawyer is one will have to save for
another day but if you want to hear more
stories about my law school experience
or my experience as an attorney check
out this short playlist I put together
it has a bunch of legal war stories and
I think you'll really enjoy the videos
so click on this playlist and I'll see
you in the next video